well it's not dangerous I think with the
events of Charleston the people who
believe in it sometimes and I often do
use it in the expression of violence
[Music]
after the Civil War you know it became
this ultimate expression of sort of
southern pride in the civil rights
movement you know it started to become a
symbol of racism and and and sort of the
fight against that that moves it towards
civil rights gives you the Oh
Confederate those are all groups that
support this flag that argue for argue
for its continued flying these are these
are things that hate the idea of a
country that is not dominated by
European groups exist very very real an
attack is either carried out restored in
every 34 days by someone from the
radical right at the United States so
this is not new I mean this level of
danger this level of violence is not new
it's been ever present
you